こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
僕は今まで様々なものをダンボールで作ってきた
時には生き物を作ったり
時には迷路を作ったり
そして時には防具を作ったり
僕昔一回防具みたいなのを作ったことがあるんですけど
今回はですね、ちょっと特殊なダンボールを準備しました
こちら
ワッショーイ！！！
開けます!
はい　というわけで、今回はこちら
カラーダンボールたるものを準備しました
というわけで、こちらに６色の
ダンボールを準備しました
このカラー段ボールを使って、ちょっと
ガチな、段ボールでガチな鎧を
作ってみようと思います。
美しい、おしゃれな装備を一式作ろうと思います
いやいやいや、今回はガチですよ
一応、五種類作る予定です。
この五種類を作っていこうと思います。
あのーこの装備系なんですけど、
僕いつも、何も考えずに作り始めるんで、
最初どう、どういうスタートで行こうかな
ってゆうのがいつも難しいんですよね。
頭の妄想力を膨らませ、はじめ
だいたいの、想像はついてきました。
ちょっと、久しぶりで鈍ってるかもしんないんで、
頑張っていきましょう！
では、いこう！！
まずは剣から作りましょう
いろんな段ボールが余ってるんで
そこでね！
なるべく固い段ボールを使って、形作りを考えていこうと思います。
はい！　というわけで、無事剣は完成しました。
こちら、黒ベースで赤のラインを入れてみました。
ちょっと、ディティールがまだ弱いんですけども、
だいたい、こんな感じですね。
ちょっと、真紅のクリムゾン感を出してみました
・・・俺の厨二病がばれてしまう・・・
やぁー、もうすっごい、こういうの大好きなんすよ
こういう感じの持ち手。
かっこいいな〜。
次は盾を作っていきましょう。
盾も多分どっちかというと赤っ、系ですね。
もう赤黒系で攻めようかなと思っているんですけど。
出来ましたっ！
盾です!
クオリティ高くないっすか?!
微妙な曲線もちゃんと書いたんで。
剣と盾は完成しました
いや、っぽいでしょ?!
ぽいぽいぽいぽいぽい
なんかもうダークナイト感がすごい
ぼく赤好きなんで、ダークナイトうー
うーこれ、ちょっ、マジ、よくね?!
よしよし。いいぞいいぞ。
まずは、かぶとからいきましょう
暗黒騎士だな、暗黒騎士のイメージでいこうか
かぶともよろいも。
かぶと作っていきましょう
はーい、出来ました。
かぶとでございまーす!
やばいな。
ちょっといかつくなっちゃったね、けっこう
昆虫の頭みたいになっちゃったんですけど、
なんだろうな、やっぱ、ちょっと
トゲトゲしたものが好きなんすよね、
多分、防具は。
まあ、ちょっと被ってみますと
まあ、こんな感じですね
もうやばいじゃん
完全にやばい人じゃん
ちょっと待ってよ
全部、赤、黒でやっちゃうと
ちょっとつまんないと思ったんで
第二の角を青にしてみました
あのー、多分、これはよろい次第ですね
どんなよろいをつけるかによって、
かぶとがどう活きるかが変わってきます
よろいの上を作りましょう
よろいはねー、作り方が難しいんだよねー
0から作ると、めちゃくちゃ時間がかかりそうなので、
ダンボールをベースにして、
考えていきましょう
はい、というわけで完成しました
よろいでございます
いやー、難しかった
あんまり、こうね、いかつくしすぎると、
逆に変だと思ったんで
ちょっと厨二病チックに
肩から何か出したいなと思って、
2本ずつ「恵方巻」をセットしました
勇者感を出したかったので、
マントをつけてみました
こんな感じです
はい、というわけで、
いよいよラストです
最後はよろいの下、
腰回りの部分を作っていこうとおもいます
では、いきましょう
よっしゃー
できま、し??!!
あ、ちょっと弱いな
よし、出来ました
よろいの下です！
こんな感じです
イナズマ入れるか迷ったんですけど、
やっぱ、赤と黒だけだとちょっとつまんないと思ったんで
どうせなら、入れました
はい、というわけで
はじめ防具一式揃いました〜!
夜の12時から始めて、
今、朝の7時です笑
まー、なかなか時間がかかったんですけども、
満足のいくものが出来たのかなとおもいます
ちょっと実際に装備してみましょう
えー、待って、待って。
めっちゃ、かっ、
うん
いやー、なんかすごいな、もう、なんか
異世界の勇者みたいになっちゃってんじゃん笑
あとは剣とたてをもてば.....
おぉ〜！！
え〜！？
いやいや、
ぽいでしょ、え、待って、
完全に勇者じゃないすか！
ちょっとクルッと回ってみましょう
あー、ダメだ
絶対に回らないほうがいいや
はい、というわけで
僕、なんとか本気で
ダンボールでガチな防具を
考えてみました!
いかがでしょうか？！
まあ、色々と言いたいことがあると思うが、
深く追及するな
これが俺の望んだ装備だ
本題はここからです
なんと、なんとですね、
今回、この僕が作ったダンボール装備
なんと、ドラゴンクエストで
作ってもらうことになりました〜！
本当にしてくれるのかな.....
はい、というわけで、
僕のこのダンボール装備
「星のドラゴンクエスト」というアプリで、
実際に作られるみたいでございます!
めっちゃ気になるんだけど、どうなってるのかな？！
これが装備できますからね
実際にドラクエで
動画の説明欄から
「星のドラゴンクエスト」
ダウンロードできますので、
よかったら、
ダウンロードしてみてください！
そして、この
はじめしゃちょー装備
実際に手に入れてみてください！
じゃあな！